hello and welcome to this video playing
wizard bar from the US that's a new
opponent let's check the profile so I
did he has kind of normal rating sir so
let's see I mean it is a given it is a
feasible looking at counter like an idea
three I can wants to do this but just
normally believed to be a little bit
more interesting and 683 mm okay thank
you three rookie one I play this in a in
a pretty conservative way there is also
a thing a set up with e for available
but I've always played it like that so
maybe this one
Bishop over 2g 30 to have fun so what I
usually like to do in this pollution
mmhmm yeah I wonder if he will take on a
three some time but it doesn't really is
that something that I have to be afraid
of and I don't know i can probably take
with a pawn it's not a big problem no
blacks position looks very very solid
the Hedgehog is a pretty good set up
against um wide formations that are not
so aggressive and this is one of them
okay I think this I don't mind this is a
somewhat better pawn structure for white
the move a5 is the key resource for
black in in some way my bishop NH 2 is
missing on the queenside this position
would be created quite nice it is nicer
than it is right here if I would have
the bishop won't be too ok yeah I'm just
I'm just going back here Bishop f3 it
just goes back i think too to see 70
maybe I should have
consider this a little bit a little bit
longer anyway let's double double on the
file
yeah I'm happy with this with this some
very sound solid structure yeah I
thought going to be to simply keeping
clean keeping everything protected he
currently only a text before once and i
also have might be five now maybe I had
it anyway but okay hmm he wants to go if
all here no and I'd be five as a good
move anyway so let's do it if he goes
each form and I moved my queen I
threaten luke t six winning the Queen at
night a 7 winning the exchange so that
doesn't look too great efore also opens
up a bishop like I mean I don't believe
in that move yeah maybe he had to he
maybe had to the thing is if I go queen
bee one there is 95
I'm not winning material right away
I have to go here right 95 97 95 to
pronounce it correctly night a seven now
now look this six wins the Queen and I
know it isn't sorry it doesn't can go to
see aid even though it looks like a very
good position I have to say um okay
still before I'm doing anything stupid
what happens here so look you one it
looks very very tempting to double i
think i should do it not think about
this any longer you cannot go 95 that
wait before I'm automatically
recapturing okay I don't see an
immediate win rock these six and 22
maybe
yeah here I don't know 196 don't see a
material win 96 looks looks dangerous
though let's do it p 5 being the threat
and he has to either give up the bishop
or go into some some discovery that
looks scary
very tough to to make a move here group
to d7 maybe wow wow didn't consider that
move not in the slightest ok this is
unprotected says something windy one is
a temple ok I think this should be good
because he doesn't have any really
attractive looking move yeah this do I
have a discovery they are 94 specially
for might be some time when he doesn't
seem to win strangely enough maybe I'm
just completely blind it wouldn't be the
first time all right f7 doesn't work
c5 is a wolf no one can take with the
Queen I come on I have to play yeah this
is nonsense what I'm doing should just
play this position which is which is
nice anyway yeah I don't think it's a
touchdown check just have to see that I
catch up a little bit on the clock check
all rights I have to have the wrong
bishop this is not check not so great
yeah it's very quick game I'm very slow
what is what him hmm no comment I just I
don't know I just fell asleep in this
position where I was hugely better
anyway and no matter what I play yeah
Queen a to Queen a 6 is actually the
strongest but it's a fantastic position
no matter what so I should just play
quickly I didn't know what did i do ii
how much time did I spend in this
position it was again utterly crazy yeah
this and now expect that believable and
you go and it's everything better with
every whatever move here just it's just
crazy check that should win this should
win this end game even read this time I
mean I didn't it Dex I didn't do it so
bad leg check I just I just like a
little bit of practice at the moment
with the super quick I mean it was just
like premium premium pre-movie okay so
yeah what was the what the issue in this
game I think it was this is pretty equal
ish I don't like this 95 I have to save
it I think it only got to go to probe
got problematic when he started to
weaken himself with a five and now
Bishop f6 the position here is very
critical yeah here why does winning it
is exactly like it happened in the game
Bishop c7 is also strong but yeah this
is what what's a bit annoying about it
was a very decently played game by white
and then I fell asleep there completely
without any reason okay well thanks for
watching